it's it's just it that's potent so if
you like potent coffee then
then i would get that
hi my name is tilani i worked at dunkin
donuts from 2015-2017 and it was my
first job ever
hi my name is liz and i'm a former
starbucks employee i worked there for
about a year and a half
i'm gonna be jittery after this video
okay so i'm gonna try the frozen coffee
the whipped cream kind of
passed away a little bit this is
different compared already just looking
at it
this is much lighter than the one at
duncan i'm gonna try this one let's see
this is good wow
that's that's quite an amount of sugar
i'm gonna end up drinking the whole
thing but this definitely not as sweet
now i'm feeling like starbucks is not as
sweet
tastes like vanilla milk kind of like i
don't know it tastes good
i'm not sure if i hate it it definitely
does not taste like a
a coffee frappuccino from starbucks but
it still
does taste pretty good
so this is the ice mocha i've never had
an ice smoker from starbucks before
i smoke a swirl
latte
this tastes like a hot chocolate i like
this i'm probably gonna get this now
[Music]
that's very sweet
i'm like a sweet person but also savory
so this kind of is like the good in
between i feel like
if you were just starting out your
coffee journey
maybe that would be like a fun time for
you
i'm gonna try the premise rule plaza
not really much of a hot coffee drinker
i will say i drink
teas for like hotness mostly so this is
gonna be interesting
this is smooth okay now that now the
aftertaste is hitting me right there
like at first i didn't really taste it i
tasted mad caramel but
after just sipping it then that then
that espresso just
i do think it holds a candle to our
caramel macchiato i just think like the
espresso we taste it more
in our drink duncan's like the fast food
of coffee
and like starbucks it's a fast food but
like more of like a
like you know has like like target like
there's walmart in target this is
like like starbucks is target it's
giving like
a little bit of bougie kind of latte i
like it it's good
so the next one i'm gonna try is the
cold brew
this is gonna be my harshest little
criticism because cold brew is what i
drink
every single day so this is cold brew
now for me i had duncan's cold brew like
once i wasn't really that much of a fan
of it i'm actually interested to taste
this one
that tastes burnt okay yeah this is the
most bitter tasting i have to say but i
think that's
like synonymous for all cold brew for me
this would have to be my least favorite
right now
that that is rough like i said i need
sweet that was okay
like it's not bitter but it's bitter to
me
we have just a regular hot black coffee
this is the drip coffee everyone
okay nope
uh it still tastes great okay this is
bitter i think
cold brew and coffee like they're bitter
this is what i imagine
people in the teacher's lounge drinking
but
duncan's has a little bit i want to say
that for its regular coffee there's a
little bit of a sweetness just a little
bit
more to its base like black coffee if i
had to pick a black coffee which i would
never pick a black coffee
it would be this would be the only one
for dunkin that's potent so if you like
potent coffee then
then i would get that i definitely am
going back to starbucks for that vanilla
fry that was great
like i'm feeling that that was really
good i will say like the caramel swirl
was very
close to our color macchiato i had to
walk
past my starbucks carrying all these
drinks
and i i couldn't even look in the window
i felt ashamed i felt like i was
betraying someone like i was cheating